[Música]
a finales del siglo 19
londres era la ciudad del mundo con
mayor cantidad de habitantes
uno de ellos se llamaba george what's
uno de los cinco millones de londinenses
que se dedica a la pintura y en 1878
realiza esta obra el jinete del caballo
blanco es una referencia al libro de la
biblia del apocalipsis es el caballo
blanco de los cuatro jinetes del
apocalipsis' la guerra la peste la
muerte y el hambre que un día un día
vendrían a solar la tierra
pero la pregunta es por qué van a
caballo digo son problemas bastante
grandes como para que tengan que subirse
a un caballo es que el caballo era la
forma de movilizarse en esa época en
londres había muchísimos caballos se
calcula que uno por cada tres y los
ambientalistas de aquel momento estaban
legítimamente preocupados
porque hacían una cuenta difícil pero
contundente si cada caballo produce 15
kilos de bonilla por día por la cantidad
de caballos eso significa que 25.000
toneladas de bonilla se depositaba en
todos los días en las calles de londres
es un montón la solución a nuestros ojos
sería muy simple hay que poner todo eso
en contenedores y sacarlo de la ciudad
el problema es que no había contenedores
todavía no los habían inventado
en la misma época si están inventando
otra cosa un motor de combustión interna
esto parecía la maravilla la gran
solución para todo lo que estaba
sucediendo
hasta el punto estaban contentos que la
primera revista de la industria
automotriz se llama la era sin caballos
porque piensan que gracias al motor
vamos a terminar con el problema de los
caballos y arreglar cualquier dificultad
la felicidad era generalizada y la
podemos ver en la cara del señor félix
que es que no importa el primer vehículo
a inglaterra en el año 1895 y acá
estamos
126 años después y tanto en mi natal
buenos aires como en mi adoptada san
jose de costa rica
este carro prahalad que funcionaba hace
126 años seguiría funcionando hoy porque
la velocidad era de 16 kilómetros por
hora y es muy parecida a la velocidad
promedio en nuestras ciudades que fue lo
que pasó entonces
bueno pasó el ciclo normal de la
tecnología
una solución que viene a resolver un
problema
termina con el tiempo generando nuevos
problemas y cuáles son esos nuevos
problemas que ha generado el motor de
combustión yo se los quisiera resumir en
esta fórmula de cero a la cuarta son los
cuatro nuevos jinetes
que ponen en riesgo a nuestra sociedad y
que deberíamos tratar en cada uno de
ellos de lograr
flor de cero
empecemos por el tráfico en costa rica
tenemos y presten atención a este dato
un vehículo por cada casi tres
habitantes si estamos como en la londres
de hace 140 años esto representa un
impacto económico del 3 8 por ciento de
nuestro producto bruto interno si no
tengo que traducir a plata para cada uno
de los que están aquí sentados o del
otro lado de la pantalla esos son 3.000
dólares por año que nos cuesta a cada
uno de nosotros
cero emisiones debería ser el objetivo
pero no estamos ahí los vehículos son
responsables del 72 por ciento de las
emisiones que se generan cero accidentes
deberíamos procurar estamos muy largo de
eso con un millón 250 mil muertes por
año en el mundo y 50 millones de heridos
donde el 30 por ciento de los accidentes
están vinculados con el consumo excesivo
de alcohol
tenemos un problema que resolver y aquí
en costa rica las cosas no son mucho
mejor
las infracciones graves público la
nación hace pocos días aumentaron en
este 2021 contra el 2020 y las
infracciones graves son aquellas como
adelantamiento indebido o exceso de
velocidad y en ese tipo de infracciones
las más difíciles el alcohol estuvo
involucrado en el 60% de las ocasiones
y el cuarto jinete es el de la
contaminación sonora deberíamos lograr
cero ruido
esto es difícil la organización mundial
de la salud dice que el nivel adecuado
debería ser de 65 decibeles
las bocinas de los carros y los pitidos
del tren llegan a valores de entre 85 y
100 decibeles
qué fue lo que pasó
imagino que algunos de ustedes se pueden
sentir abrumados ante esta contundencia
de los datos y pensar bueno a lo mejor
lo que silvio nos va a decir ahora es
que volvamos a los caballos pero antes
de que algunos saques esa conclusión los
quiero invitar a recordar dos cosas
primero
que los vehículos también trajeron cosas
buenas desde las ambulancias a los
carros de bomberos desde los transportes
de estudiantes hasta los buses de
turismo
y segundo recuerden esas toneladas de
bonn y gas que se acumulan en las casas
se acumulan en las calles y pregúntense
cuántas ganas tienen de volver a
convivir con eso entonces lo que nos
tenemos que preguntar hoy aquí es qué
podemos hacer y les traigo aquí una
solución carros voladores
no se rían son verdad en 10 ó 20 años en
10 ó 20 años
vamos a ver cruzando los cielos
vehículos electrificados probablemente
autónomos que van a estar llevando
pasajeros esto ya es en etapa de prueba
hay empresas haciendo
testeos de este tipo de tecnología
pero para las urgencias que tenemos hoy
aquí en costa rica es algo demasiado
futurista entonces les quiero compartir
otras cuatro ideas de cosas que podemos
empezar a hacer tan pronto como
terminemos las charlas de hoy lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es mejorar la
calidad de nuestro parque automotor y
para eso es importantísimo que empecemos
entendiendo que no todos los carros son
iguales y les voy a dar varios ejemplos
menos del 2 por ciento de los vehículos
que circulan
son autobuses y taxis y sin embargo
explican el 11 por ciento de las
emisiones
15% de los vehículos son de carga pero
generan el 40% de las emisiones si
agarramos a un mismo fabricante y al
mismo modelo de carro y lo comparamos
las emisiones que produce hoy contra las
que producía 15 años atrás
ese carro hoy emite 30% menos y si
agarramos a un mismo fabricante y
ponemos uno a la par del otro un
vehículo híbrido y un vehículo de
gasolina el híbrido emite entre un 58 y
un 67% menos según los estudios que
hicimos aquí en san jose con el tráfico
real de san jose lo que les quiero decir
con todos estos datos es que tenemos que
enfocarnos en nuestro esfuerzo no todos
los vehículos son iguales tenemos que
pensar dónde está el nudo de la
contaminación y atacarlo tenemos que
darnos cuenta que nuestra flota
vehicular es muy antigua tiene 17 años
en promedio y eso significa que utiliza
una tecnología y altamente contaminante
todavía debemos pensar un proceso
ordenado y considerado por el cual
podamos ir retirando de las calles las
tecnologías obsoletas y si alguien
insistiera todavía en circular
deberíamos pensar en que pague un
impuesto mayor por el daño que le
produce al medio ambiente
lo siguiente que tenemos que hacer es
trabajar sobre la demanda el 96% del
tiempo los carros permanecen parqueados
y si uno mira desde el punto de vista de
la capacidad de transporte el 11 por
ciento de la capacidad de transportar
pasajeros es lo que se utiliza
promover la movilidad compartida es una
gran contribución a resolver estos
problemas
y no solamente la movilidad compartida
privada sino también la pública y un
gran paso sería por ejemplo dotar a los
taxis a los trenes oa los autobuses de
los sistemas de visibilidad y traqueo
que hoy tenemos en la movilidad privada
para que cualquier persona que está
esperando su transporte público pueda en
su teléfono ver dónde está y cuando
llega
tenemos que hacer un uso mayor y mejor
de la tecnología
les quiero contar la historia de un
colega mío lewis mumford que él decía
que pensar en resolver el problema de la
congestión vehícular agregando carriles
carece de tanto sentido como si yo
quisiera resolver mi problema de
obesidad
simplemente agrandando la faja no
funciona de esa manera y pensemos por
ejemplo en los aeropuertos y las torres
de control
originalmente eran altas para que los
operadores en forma visual ordenen los
tráficos el tráfico de los aviones que
llegaban y de los que iban a despegar
todo eso se automatizó se computarizado
ya no se puede manejar un aeropuerto con
esa tecnología pero nosotros seguimos
manejando nuestro tráfico con esa
tecnología tenemos que volver los
carriles y los parqueos
inteligentes para que se sepan acomodar
al tráfico y a la demanda de cada
momento del día
y no sé si a ustedes les habrá pasado
pero yo tengo demasiadas malas
experiencias subiendo la cuesta de santa
anna o por ochomogo o saliendo a correr
a la manía por la sabana de tener que
ver esas bocanadas de humo negro
espantoso que sale de ciertos vehículos
y pensar cómo es posible y en realidad
es muy posible de terminar con ese
problema todo lo que tenemos que hacer
es colocar un sensor en el vehículo un
sensor que ya existe que no solamente
iba a informar el nivel de emisiones
sino que además puede reportarlo y eso
va a generar además ingresos
el último punto que quiero marcar es la
necesidad imperiosa que tenemos de
modernizar la legislación
siempre de toda la vida la tecnología va
más rápido que los legisladores y para
que no se ensañen especialmente con los
que tenemos ahorita en costa rica les
cuento que al principio
pasaron más de 30 años entre la
invención del automóvil y la licencia de
conducir
durante más de 30 años la gente se podía
simplemente montar a un carro y salir
nadie y verificaba si sabía cómo se
hacía o si estaba violando alguna ley o
si le importaba la vida de cualquier
persona así de lenta iba la legislación
pero finalmente lo lograba en esa misma
línea el on más dice que en algún
momento va a estar prohibido que los
seres humanos conduzcamos
justamente por la gran cantidad de
accidentes que provocamos yo no sé pero
creo que hay dos o tres personas que
todos los días podrían fácilmente
calificar para que les aplique esa ley
tenemos que hacer cosas ya y la primera
es trabajar sobre el concepto de
tecnologías más limpias hay una falsa
dicotomía que dice que las tecnologías
se dividen en contaminantes y no
contaminantes eso no es así podemos
promover tecnologías de transición que
nos hagan entender que hay tecnologías
más contaminantes menos contaminantes y
nada contaminantes y si empezamos a
migrar del grupo de los más
contaminantes hacia los que menos y los
que nada vamos a estar muchísimo mejor
lo segundo a nivel de legislación que
hay que hacer es castigar a las
emisiones eso tenemos que hacerlo y
rápidamente y lo tercero que tenemos que
hacer es regular a las plataformas de
movilidad compartida están entre
nosotros desde hace mucho tiempo y nadie
les termina finalmente como decimos en
argentina de poner el cascabel al gato
lo último es quizás vinculado con eso es
la sobreabundancia
multiplicidad maraña burocrática de
instituciones que tenemos tenemos que
simplificar la cantidad de organismos
que trabajan con este tema
podemos lograr imposibles estas no son
sueños como el carro volador que les
mostraba al principio los imposibles los
demostramos el martes con aquel gol
agónico en el minuto 94 que nos puso de
vuelta con vida en el camino hacia qatar
con costa rica pero también
hubo un imposible la semana pasada el
martes en glasgow escocia donde en el
contexto de la cob 26 un grupo de
empresas reconoce costarricenses fue
reconocida por las instituciones
europeas
y ganaron una significativa cantidad de
dinero para poner en marcha un proyecto
piloto en el que nadie había pensado
todavía usted 600 empresas y propuestas
que participaron de las cuales 41 fueron
elegidas finalistas y 4 fueron elegidas
ganadoras una de las cuales es
costarricense y generó un proyecto
centrado en el hidrógeno verde para
resolver el problema del transporte de
carga y de autobuses aquí en costa rica
con ideas nuevas
valientes con mucho trabajo
podemos evitar que caiga sobre nosotros
un apocalipsis que nos afecte tanto a
nosotros como a nuestros hijos si
pudimos resolver el problema de los
caballos vamos a poder resolver también
los problemas de la movilidad la
movilidad es inherente a las personas la
movilidad nos define como seres humanos
la movilidad nos hace felices a nosotros
y es uno de los momentos más lindos de
nuestras vidas como padres cuando vemos
a los hijos que comienzan a gatear
que se ponen de pie y que son capaces de
andar por sí mismos o cuando lo vemos
montarse a una bicicleta y lanzarse
solos al camino
hay cosas que podemos hacer hoy mismo
promover la movilidad compartida
establecer una preferencia muy marcada
por tecnologías limpias
promover un diálogo en torno a la
movilidad en todas nuestras esferas de
trabajo o de estudio o de actividad
política es algo que le debemos a
nuestros hijos dejarles un mundo con una
movilidad más confiable y sostenible
muchísimas gracias por su atención y
buenas tardes
[Aplausos]
[Música]